we're starting to shoot and I'm so happy
cuz like we're locked in finally but you
could die I could die and then we can't
shoot anymore you
know
leg
apprach used to be now taking your like
robber damn if think they put the video
up the same night I think it was like a
th000 6,000 the 10,000 and it just kept
going up like it went
viral
everybody was talking about
it super raw super
real I think sometimes I just can't
believe this is all happening for
me Tiara do you really know where your
thoughts come
from probably best if you just don't
film this
part all pop culture is a form of Mind
Control maybe it's not all evil but it's
incepting someone's brain systems of
power never go
away they just
evolve you never truly know who's
watching tell the
[Music]
truth